♪ ♪
>> Greg: A CASE WHERE BEING
NUMBER ONE MEANS REALLY YOU ARE
NUMBER TWO.
A NEW STUDY RANKS CALIFORNIA
DEAD LAST OF ALL THE STATES, AND
QUALITY OF LIFE, MAKING IT TOXIC
BEING ON THE BOTTOM.
STATES WERE RANKED ON EVERYTHING
INFRASTRUCTURE, CRIME.
CALIFORNIA SCORED LOW FOR ONE
SIMPLE REASON: IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
TO LIVE THERE UNLESS YOU ARE
SUPER RICH OR HOMELESS.
THEN COME ONE, COME ALL.
RENTING A TRUCK TO GO FROM
SAN FRANCISCO TO DALLAS COSTS
3200 BUCKS.
THE RETURN TRIP ONLY 1100.
UP 180%.
THAT'S BASED ON THE TRUCK
SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO MANY PEOPLE ARE LEAVING ONE
LEFT-WING CITY FOR A MORE
AFFORDABLE ONE.
MAYBE CALIFORNIANS LEAVING
CALIFORNIA NOW, THOSE ARE THE
REAL DREAMERS.
ANYONE WHO WAS BEEN TO L.A.
KNOWS IT'S TURNED INTO A
POST-APOCALYPTIC WASTELAND WITH
55,000 HOMELESS IN THAT COUNTY
ALONE.
MASSIVE ENCAMPMENTS HAVE
ENVELOPED SKID ROW UNDER
OVERPASSES IN STREETS NEARBY.
SAN FRANCISCO ISN'T MUCH BETTER.
SPENDING MILLIONS ON CLEANING UP
HUMAN WASTE LEFT ON ITS STREETS
BY THE HOMELESS.
WE ARE LIVING IN A TIME WHERE
HOLLYWOOD EMBRACES DYSTOPIAN
FICTION.
THEY SPEND MILLIONS TRYING TO
RECREATE THE LOCAL LIFE AFTER
NUCLEAR WAR.
I COULD SAVE THEM SOME MONEY.
I'M GOING TO GO TO YOU, JUAN.
I NEVER GO TO YOU FIRST.
MAYBE TIME TO ASK THIS QUESTION.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE OF POOR.
MASSIVE GOVERNMENT SERVICES.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU, SIR?
>> Juan: THAT THEY ARE MEETING
THE NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE?
>> Greg: THEY ARE NOT.
>> Juan: THEY HAVE A HUGE
HOMELESS POPULATION IN THE
GOVERNMENT SPENDING A LOT OF
MONEY.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE VILLAGES.
>> Juan: I THINK THE REAL
REASON THEY ARE RANKED AT THE
INTERACTION FROM WHAT I READ.
I AM SAYING I THINK YOU ARE ON
TARGET AND SAYING IT IS LIKE THE
RICH.
YOU CAN LIVE A FABULOUS LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU ARE NOT RICH, THEN YOUR
RENT IS TOO HIGH.
PEOPLE DON'T INTERACT.
IT'S NOT A COMMUNAL TYPE PLACE.
EVERYONE IS IN THEIR OWN PRIVATE
SPACE.
TO ME, I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR YOU.
WHY ARE CONSERVATIVES DELIGHTING
IN CALIFORNIA BEING RANKED AS
THE WORST?
>> Greg: WE LIKE TO BE PROVEN
CORRECT.
WHEN HE'S SEEN MASSIVE LIBERAL
BUREAUCRACIES FAIL, WE GO, WHY
DIDN'T YOU LISTEN TO US?
I AM STAT I HAVE TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA.
I AM FROM THERE.
>> Jesse: INCOME INEQUALITY,
POLLUTION, SEGREGATED
NEIGHBORHOODS.
OH IT'S RUN BY DEMOCRATS.
ALL THE THINGS DEMOCRATS SAY
THEY ARE AGAINST.
THEY ARE DOING IT IN THEIR OWN
STATE.
I'VE BEEN A SKID ROW.
IT WAS THE SCARIEST MOMENT OF MY
LIFE.
I'VE BEEN TO EVERY NEIGHBORHOOD,
SOUTHSIDE OF CHICAGO, DETROIT.
I DID NOT LEAVE THE CAR.
A BUNCH OF WHITE GUYS WITH
EXPENSIVE CAMERAS WALKED OUTSIDE
AND THESE ENCAMPMENTS.
IT IS LIKE ARMAGEDDON.
POST-APOCALYPTIC.
YOU HAVE ZOMBIES ON DRUGS
WANDERING AROUND.
NEEDLES EVERYWHERE.
NO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT IS A LOT LESS, CHAOS.
IT'S DIRTY, INFESTED.
THE SCARIEST PLACE ON EARTH.
YOU WOULD THINK IT WAS A THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY.
IT IS RIGHT NEXT TO CITY HALL
AND THEY TOLERATE IT.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT LIKE A SKID
ROW CONCERT WHICH IS ACTUALLY
ENJOYABLE.
KIMBERLY, YOU ARE FROM THE BAY
AREA.
>> Kimberly: BORN AND RAISED
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
IT IS VERY SAD GOING ON THERE.
LIBERAL POLITICS, THEY THINK
THIS IS WHAT LOVE SHOULD LOOK
LIKE.
YOU TRASH YOUR CITY.
YOU ALLOW ANYTHING GOES.
YOU HAVE SANCTUARY CITIES.
LET THE CITIZENS GET MURDERED.
LAWLESSNESS, AND NO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
>> Greg: WHO WAS GOING TO BE
THE NEXT GOVERNOR?
>> Kimberly: I THINK GAVIN
NEWSOM.
HE IS IN A TIGHT RACE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A BATTLE.
>> Greg: HE'S NOT A TYPICAL
LIBERAL.
>> Kimberly: WHEN HE WAS MAYOR
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
>> Juan: THE ECONOMY THERE IS
TERRIFIC.
>> Greg: FOR SOME PEOPLE.
>> Juan: THE FOURTH BEST
ECONOMY IN THE NATION.
>> Greg: SILICON VALLEY AND
HOLLYWOOD.
>> Dana: I LIVED IN SAN DIEGO
FOR THREE YEARS.
'99 UNTIL I WENT BACK TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IN 2001.
SAN DIEGO HAS BEEN RUN BY
CONSERVATIVES AND REPUBLICAN,
THE COUNTY.
NOT NECESSARILY.
THE MAYOR IS A REPUBLICAN.
I THINK HE STILL CALLS HIMSELF
THAT.
DEMOCRATS WILL SAY ERIC
GARCETTI, THE MAYOR OF
LOS ANGELES, THEY TALK ABOUT HIM
IS A REALISTIC CANDIDATE FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2020.
>> Kimberly: HE HAS A NICE.
[LAUGHTER]